المترجم: Riyad Almubarak
المدقّق: Duaa Elfadil
المشاكل في السودان في جوانب الصحة
والتعليم والاقتصاد كلها مشاكل متداخلة.
تشبه صندوق المناديل، ما أن تسجب
أحدها حتى يخرج ثلاثة.
المشكلة التي نعمل على حلها حالياً،
هي مشكلة التبرع بالدم.
دائماً ما تكون الحوجة أكثر من عدد
المتبرعين بالدم وهذه مشكلة حقيقية.
متوسط الحوجة الشهرية في ولاية
الخرطوم فقط،
10320 وحدة، غير الحاجة للدم الطازج
للعمليات المباشرة.
يوجد مرضى بحاجة إلى عمليات ينتظرون
توفر الدم منذ قرابة الشهرين.
نساء يعانين في غرف الولادة وأحيانا يتوفين
بسبب النزيف لعدم توفر متبرعين.
مرضى سرطان لا تتحسن حالتهم لأن الطبيب
يحدد لهم 20 زجاجة دم يتوفر منها فقط اثنين.
الحوادث المرورية يتوفر لها دم عن طريق
التبرع الطوعي فقط.
ما هو الحلّ؟
هناك جانبين: أحدهما رسمي والآخر مجتمعي
الجانب الرسمي يختص بسلامة
الدم وتخزينه.
الجانب المجتمعي هو الذي أوليناه اهتمامنا.
به حل آني وحل مرحلي وحل مستقبلي
وسنتحدث عن الحل الآني فقط.
أنشأنا قاعدة بيانات نسجل فيها الراغبين
في التبرع بالدم مثلكم.
عندما تكون هناك حوجة مطابقة، تصلهم
إشعارات فورية بناءً عليها يتبرعون بالدم.
التسجيل حسب فصيلة الدم وأقرب مستشفى لك
كي لا يسبب لك ذلك إرهاقاً والزمن
المناسب للإتصال بك.
إن دخلتم على موقعنا الإلكتروني ستجدون
الإستمارة لملئها وستصلكم هذه الإشعارات.
أطلقنا المشروع في العام 2012
كان أول موقع إلكتروني سوداني للتبرع بالدم.
أجرينا لقاءات إعلامية،
تواصلنا مع منظمة الصحة العالمية،
ذهبنا إلى تركيا واتطلعنا على تجربتهم
والتي أفادتنا بالحل المستقبلي الذي سيحل
مشكلة الدم في السودان والدول الأخرى.
نتجاوز هذا --
نتجاوز هذا أيضاً --
المرحلة الثالثة نسدّ فيها حوجتنا وقد نعمل
على تصدير الدم ونحصل على أدوية مقابله.
كيف؟ في 30 ثانية فقط --
سوف ننشئ منهجاً لا صفياً يدرّس في المدارس
حتى يغرس في الطفل
ثقافة التبرع بالدم وحب العطاء
وحب الغير وإنقاذ حياة الناس،
لذا عندما يكبر لا يحتاج أن يتم إرشاده
بل يذهب للتبرع بالدم من تلقاء نفسه.
أخيراً، نحلم بمركز اتصال يكون
متاحاً للمحتاجين دوماً،
نحلم بشاشات يمكن من خلالها
التسجيل من أي مكان،
نحلم بهذا الحلّ
يقوم صاحب الحوجة بأخذ الدم في زجاجة
وعن طريق المواصلات العامة،
مما يؤدي إلى إفساد الدم.
أتدرون أين يطبّق هذا الحلّ؟
في رواندا، هكذا يتم نقل الدم.
نحلم بأن نسدّ حوجتنا من الدم.
شكراً جزيلاً.
(تصفيق)